lots of great games week two ten of them
big cat in that one p.m eastern window
last week was a nice balance seven early
five late this week ten early three late
and let's start with the pittsburgh
steelers limping home after being
splattered by the new england patriots
33-3 income the seahawks and you know
heinz field intimidating place to play
for the visiting team but the seahawks
are a team that doesn't seem to get
intimidated on the road i i think that
that they understand the value of home
field advantage so well that they're
able to almost counter program when
they're the ones on the other end of it
i don't think the seahawks are going to
have uh the kind of tough day that many
believe i think the steelers are flawed
on both sides of the ball based upon
what we saw on sunday night and i think
the seahawks are exactly what the
steelers need to be run the ball and
play style defense
uh mike i actually listened to the sims
unbutton podcast or at least a portion
of it and i heard your take about the
seahawks having a good home field
advantage that that means that they can
have a good road advantage because they
know what a good home advantage is that
is by far and away the dumbest thing
i've ever heard anyone say no it's not
no i like now trust me i have said
dumber things than that just this week i
don't know but i i just think that i
think that they are it's almost like we
get this we know how this works we see
what other teams struggle with so we
learn from their struggles when we take
it on the road do you mean to tell me
pete carroll hasn't studied how other
teams deal with the home field advantage
in seattle and apply those messages to
himself when he goes on the road and
wins in places like foxborough no i
stand by what i said that was the
dumbest thing you've ever said
steelers 16 and nine there's no way
you'd listen to that someone fed that no
no i listen to me i honestly listen i
drove up from brooklyn this morning to
stanford i listened and i almost crashed
my car because i was so confused that
what your point was it made no sense
well i wish you had steelers oh wow
steelers
that's good i actually like that
steelers 16-9 against the spread off of
a loss since 2014 i'm a big believer and
you're never as bad as you were last
week especially week one i think the
steelers are going to win this game i
think they're going to cover the spread
are we doing spreads i think they're
going to cover this spread we're not
doing spreads but
they're going to cover the spread i like
the steelers in this game all right no
spreads but they're going to cover the
spread yeah i just think the seahawks i
just look i and and last night is the
prime example of trust nothing that you
saw last week right because the
buccaneers were horrible at home against
the 49ers and they go on the road and
they kick the butts of the panthers so
that's one of the reasons why we love
this sport it's so unpredictable week in
and week out and every time you think
you have it figured out you don't and
that's kind of why
i don't know i just i i think the
seahawks
can do the things the steelers need to
do and the steelers can't do the things
they need to do and they're going to
feel and that look with pressure
there's so much and sims tells this
story about just when you're 0-1 heading
into that second game you really do
start to feel it because you don't want
to go 0-2 and everybody's a little bit
tighter that week as you're heading into
that game where you may be 0-2 the
steelers are going to be feeling very
tight this week and they got a tough
opponent coming in and they desperately
need to win this game to avoid following
the owen two especially given how good
the ravens looked week one i mean i know
the ravens weren't actually playing an
nfl team but they still look pretty good
i think that that sets the stage for the
seahawks to steal this one i like them
to win the game straight up okay one
last quick point before we go to the
next game i'm a big i'm a big colors guy
i close my eyes i see the seahawks
colors on the road and they just aren't
as intimidating
now you're being sarcastic no that's
exactly you're trying to say something
even dumber than i said no what i said
is correct you when you close your hands
think about this how is that
not dumber than me having a very well
reasoned take that the seahawks have
studied the failures of their opponents
in that loud setting and they have
learned from it and they know how to
deal with hostile crowds on the road
that is a well-reasoned take yours is
just flat out stupid talk everyone who's
listening right now knows exactly what
i'm talking about if you close your eyes
you envision the game you can always see
what's going to happen if you think
about the jersey colors
vikings at packers lambeau field last
week or last year rather week two at
lambeau field these two teams played to
a tie this year you know it's kind of
intriguing because the offenses are very
similar so the defenses kind of have a
little bit of an edge in figuring out
how to stop the other team's offense how
do you see that one playing out the
vikings did the vikings figure out what
they need to do with kirk cousins and by
that i mean just have him not play
quarterback because he threw 10 passes
on sunday and it was successful 98 yards
i i don't know when the last time a team
had 8 for 10 98 yards from their
starting quarterback and won
convincingly
i think though the packers defense is
very very good i think that they made
the bears look very bad obviously on
thursday but they upgraded across the
board in the offseason
i think the packers are going to win
this game i also think aaron rodgers is
not going to look as uncomfortable as he
did opening night against the bears
because that offense with matt lafleur
is going to get better week to week
they're still kind of learning
everything and figuring each other out
well but here's the thing last week
against the bears there was just one
drive where aaron rodgers kind of kind
of woke up and and it was funny because
we were making fun of the packers while
we were watching the game because they
were coming out of a timeout and then
they took a time out and and aaron
rodgers stayed out on the field like he
used to do with mike mccarthy when he'd
call a timeout sometimes and then four
play 74 yards the packers scored the
touchdown with that weird little jump
ball that he threw to jimmy graham other
than that it was an uninspiring
performance and this is a
not a better defense but i think a
defense is going to be better suited to
cracking the code on that offense
because there's a lot of similarities
matt lafleur was a quality control
assistant under gary kubiak at one point
and gary kubiak is now integrally
involved in getting the vikings offense
into the spot where we saw it last week
i i think the vikings are the better
team and i know that lambeau field gives
the packers a built-in advantage but i
don't think it's enough
when you look at the way dalvin cook and
alexander madison ran the ball last week
for the vikings they didn't need kirk
cousins to throw the ball now look they
they had plays in special teams little
block punt they get a short field they
get an interception they get a short
field they didn't have to do much
offensively but that running game is
potent and they're going to keep riding
that running game and they're going to
use kirk cousins not only 10 times this
week but i don't think you're going to
see kirk cousins throw it around like he
did last year at lambeau field this is
the formula that mike zimmer has wanted
from the moment he became the head coach
of the vikings and they finally have the
offensive line the strategy the running
backs to do it and and i think the
vikings will grind out the win okay i
mean you make you make some good points
i just think that the packers their
defense is uh very
you know big time upgrade and i think
aaron rodgers is going to get better
week to week patriots dolphins should we
even talk about this one is this a trap
for the patriots they're one and five in
miami last year when the vikings were up
or were favored by 17 over the bills the
bills won the game straight up do the
dolphins wake up and and make this even
remotely interesting no they don't and i
actually will flip it with you if you
want to discuss anything here when was
the last time a team openly tanked to
this degree this early in the season i
can't remember it i cannot remember it i
don't know it's never happened i don't
know how this team this dolphins team
gets up for games on sunday knowing that
everyone from the the owner on down is
basically saying let's lose as many
games as possible and get as many draft
picks and all you guys right now you
probably won't be on the team in a year
or two and to go out there and play hard
you know tough football that's a that's
a big time ask this early in the season
this is the first nba style trust to
process full season tank that we've seen
in the nfl i'm a firm believer once
you're out of the playoffs there's no
incentive to win any more games because
who cares if you're 6 and 10 or 4 and 12
or 3 and 13. finish as low as you can so
you draft as high as you can but still
try to make the playoffs don't kick into
that mode until you know you're not
going to make the playoffs the dolphins
are just accepting week one we ain't
gonna make the playoffs let's go ahead
and be as bad as we can be and uh yeah i
don't know it's gonna be 59 to 10 but
the patriots should be able to handle
them uh quite easily on sunday chargers
lions this one's intriguing to me
chargers escaped with a win in overtime
lions played to a draw in overtime who
do you like i like the lions in this
game and i i'm putting my trust in matt
patricia who i thought had a really
really bad second half uh in arizona i
felt like they went away from everything
they were doing well they were passing
on early downs in the first half then
they started running the ball a lot they
were kind of doing the old-fashioned
playing uh to not lose not playing to
win and also i think kyle murray when
they when they simplified that offense
and it got to the fourth quarter and he
was just kind of slinging the ball
around that's when you saw the cardinals
emerge there at the end and simplified
everything i just think the chargers
going to the eastern time zone and the
lions looking like they have a lot i
i've been
not high on the lions but i think they
have a ton of talent and i think they
will be able to run the ball against the
chargers i think they will be able to
learn from last week and it is kind of a
must win because if the lions want to do
anything like you said starting on two
has a lot of pressure so i like the
lions to win this game run the ball run
the ball run the ball keep your defense
off the field that's a way to keep them
fresh late and i think the lions will
pull it out we agree on one finally well
we agreed on patriots also colts titans
titans shocked the browns colts hung in
there against the charges they get
together in nashville a rematch of last
year's playoff play in game who do you
like steve mcnair and eddie george
retirement uh game give me the titans
all day that's all you need to know i
did we don't need to analyze any x's and
o's off that one that never is a thing
though that's never a factor
that never matters you are exposing
yourself for not knowing anything about
football let me tell you something i can
go back through plenty of years where
you assume oh they're going to win
tonight because if they're retiring
so-and-so's jersey they're putting this
guy in the in the ring of honor and it
ultimately doesn't matter it's
irrelevant
you're talking about guys who might be
still alive steve mcnair is a legend he
passed away tragically that makes all
the difference in the world i'll take
the titans i think the titans are a
little on a little bit of a mission i
think they've been disrespected i also
think the colts as good as they played i
have big time questions about the
chargers defense without derwin james
last week and the you know the colts had
that
comeback at the end of the game i think
the titans are going to be better
defensively than the chargers were so i
will take the titans even though i hate
their offense and i really do hate their
offense i will take the titans in this
game
i i talked to safety kevin byrd after
the game last week when they thumped the
browns and there was something in his
voice that and i know that look but
there was a confidence there and and and
there was a hey this wasn't about the
browns this is about us we're trying to
go from being a good team to a great
team and when we get on the plane we're
going to start focusing on the colts and
we're going to forget about the browns
and that you know mike frable has shown
that he can coach that team into a spot
where it wins games against better teams
now they have to hold serve against
teams that they should beat and you
should look at this game and say based
upon the andrew luck retirement the
titans should win this is a great early
season test if the titans can win a game
they should win and i think they will
that is a better explanation than
they're retiring the jerseys of eddie
george and steve mcnair nope i
like i said i could we could have
stopped the conversation as soon as i
said they're retiring the jerseys of
eddie george and steve mcnair eddie
george will probably come out in a steve
mcnair jersey and there will not be a
dry eye in the house
mitchell trubisky and the chicago bears
head to denver to take on vic fangio's
broncos big cat and look the bears had
extra time
the broncos are operating on a short
week
maybe there's a little bit of edge there
that goes to chicago bears maybe the
bear and i don't think the broncos
looked all that good monday night maybe
the bears can avoid falling to owen too
what do you think
it's uh i'll say it it's a must win it's
a must win because there are some doubts
there that uh this is this whole thing's
gonna work out so it is the rare week
two must win
going to denver in september with the
altitude and the heat has not been good
for the opponents so
i am worried as bears fan but more than
anything
matt nagy and mr biski
coming away from that thursday night
game there were more questions than
answers and i think most people are
scratching their head and saying
is this going to work and when you have
that long 10 days between games the
questions continue the narrative
continues
people just want to see the bears play
again
they gotta wait all the way till 4 25 on
sunday afternoon so
the questions will keep going until that
point until they get out there kick the
ball and we can see the bears do
something different than score three
points at home against the packers
what do you make of the bears telling
trubisky when meeting with reporters
this week to not talk about last week's
loss to the packers and trubisky saying
out loud they told me not to talk about
last week's laws to the packers i think
it's crazy and i think it's
short-sighted and i think what the bears
are struggling with right now from a
media perspective is the idea of
expectation chicago is a football town
and people are expecting the bears to be
a good team after last year's dream
season and if you don't handle the media
well if you don't know how to navigate
these simple press conferences
this will this will kind of blow up in
your face quickly mitch trubisky should
have gotten in front of the media
earlier than wednesday as well because
of course the media is going to ask him
about the packers game i don't care that
it was thursday to wednesday and there
had been you know an entire weekend in
between that was the first time he got
in front of everyone after the post game
press conference people are going to ask
what happened what he learned from to to
deny him from answering those questions
just it leads to more questions and
conversations like this so i can't stand
it when when a team just doesn't you
know come out and say hey look this is
the deal we screwed up we're getting
better it was just a weird way to handle
the whole thing and the bear season has
not started the way i thought it would
jaguars at texans both of those teams
0-1 jaguars were going to have a hard
time with the chiefs no matter what
texans had the game one in new orleans
deshawn watson took 11 hits six sacks
somehow he's not on the injury report
this week but here come the jaguars who
have the guys up front to shred that
offensive line can the texans buy enough
time for desean watson to score enough
points to out duel gardner minshew the
second who steps in at quarterback for
the jaguars gardner minshew the second
whose father's name is not gardner one
of the greatest stories ever did you
know that mike
well it's like art rooney the second his
father's name is an art okay well i
don't know how how he's not uncommon
second that's right that's a way you
avoid the j it would otherwise be junior
okay there you go uh i think the texans
will win this game but this is gonna be
a competitive game the jaguars are gonna
keep keep this close uh you know the
texans you i'm sure you've talked about
this mike but deshawn watson and the
hits he takes
and the inability for bill o'brien to
figure out a way to keep desean watson
from taking this type of punishment i've
seen i've seen the stats thrown out
there on twitter i think people are kind
of taking one situation and applying it
to another which i hate to do but there
has been that conversation about deshaun
watson is on pace to have more hits than
andrew luck was and andrew luck just
retired at the age of 29. i'm not saying
those are apples to apples but
it's a conversation worthy of being had
because you have a young dynamic
quarterback that is a game-changing
franchise quarterback and you can't keep
him from getting absolutely crushed game
in and game out
and he does not have that body type that
would suggest he can withstand that type
of a beating he is not a big tall thick
guy he is kind of wiring for the most
part he can avoid contact down the field
when he gets swallowed up behind the
line of scrimmage is when he is in the
most danger and we saw it plenty on
monday night i think we're gonna see it
even more against the jaguars on sunday
cardinals and the ravens getting
together on sunday lamar jackson tyler
murray i hope this game ends up being
exciting i hope the cardinals can move
the ball and score some points against
the ravens because this has the
potential to be a great great game big
cat how do you think it plays out
i think the ravens are going to beat
them handily what the cardinals did on
sunday against the lions the comeback
that they had
i don't think they're going to run that
same offense the reason why that
comeback worked for the cardinals is
they basically were just getting up to
the line of scrimmage and going and and
having guys run the same routes and kyle
murray was simplified and i don't think
that you can do that for four quarters
and expect to have that result so i
think the ravens are a significantly
better team
and kyler murray what we saw in the
first half against the lions i think
we're going to see on sunday against the
ravens yeah i agree with you i think
what happened was the lions got up
comfortably 24-6 they they softened
things up and all of a sudden the
cardinals woke up and the lions got
tired the next thing you know they were
in overtime and and the cardinals should
have won that game if tremaine brock
does not try to catch an interception of
matthew stafford with his face the
cardinals potentially win that game in
overtime ca and i so i i think the
ravens win i just hope it's an exciting
game but i have a feeling it won't be
cowboys in washington this is my upset
special of the week big cat last week it
was titans over the browns this week
it's washington over the cowboys we've
seen washington play well at home for
some reason because that stadium is kind
of a crap hole but uh adrian peterson
angry motivated determined punishing the
dallas front seven dallas may be feeling
a little too good about themselves after
how well it went at home week one
against the giants this is a trap for
the cowboys and i think they're going to
step right into it i don't hate the
reasoning there and you know you have a
divisional game early in the season take
the home team kind of feel to it i just
think the cowboys offense is going to be
really really good and i don't know as
much as you know you love case keenum
for that one year in minnesota and he
can do some things as the quarterback i
just don't know if they'll be able to
keep up with a dallas offense that you
know you saw it the play action i think
they ran play they ran play action a ton
on sunday it feels like kelmore's got
everything working for him uh on an
offensive side and dak prescott looked
fantastic he is playing for a contract i
always like motivated players like that
ezekiel elliott one more game in he only
got 13 carries on sunday against the
giants
i think the cowboys are going to win
this game i just think they're the more
talented team overall
game of the afternoon saints and rams
get together at the la coliseum last
year's nfc championship game hovers over
it even though it's irrelevant what's
relevant is this year's nfc championship
game because the winner has the leg up
in the tiebreaker
and also picking up the raw victory that
would determine where the game will be
played in january if there is a rematch
how do you see this one playing out i
take the rams here i mean the saints are
a different team away from the dome a
different team on grass you know it's i
do usually say my theory usually is if
you have a good home advantage that
teaches you how to have a good road
advantage uh which makes no sense but
you know whatever it doesn't really
matter uh so i think the saints on the
grass against the rams i'll take the
rams here uh i think the rams
jared goff wasn't great week one and i
think he's the type of guy that that if
you see a bad game from week one he's
gonna he's gonna be able to correct
those mistakes especially with sean
mcvay i like the rams to win this game
how does the visualizing the saints
road uniforms factor into your analysis
in this one did you want to comment on
me just repeating your dumb quote back
to you and seeing how dumb it sounded uh
you want to comment on me
repeating your dumb quote back to you
yeah the saints road jersey close your
eyes i don't like the saints on the road
i don't like their jerseys so yeah i'd
like the rams
my cousin texted me big cat probably
picks teams based on if mascots fight
who would win is that a factor at all
for you actually if you want me to do a
plug right now pardon my take today we
have coach mike leach and we went
through a bunch of mascots we went
through the top ten in college football
which mascot would beat a cougar no joke
well that's good
and there you go uh maybe he got
advanced access to pardon my take all
right chiefs raiders get together blow
out right right it was supposed to be a
blowout monday night of the raiders but
they can't stop patrick mahomes yes the
raiders had everything going for them on
monday night they all got you know
galvanized around the antonio brown
story patrick mahomes is on another
level even without tyree kill andy reid
schemes everyone open i think the chiefs
win this one easily
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports